good morning John in 2012 on September
11th a group of militants attacked the
US consulate in Benghazi Libya now three
years later if you live in America the
word Benghazi is either one of those
words that gets you real riled up or
it's a word that if you hear it you're
got to get ready to run away from
whatever nearby person is about to get
real riled up it's one of those topics
that you either know a whole lot about
or you know pretty much nothing about
the trouble is learning about Benghazi
is no matter what going to expose you to
a great deal of partisan anger entering
out why this is what actually happened
what it means and hopefully removing it
a little bit from that crazy angry
partisan grandstanding is what we're
going to try to do in the next seven
minutes let's start out with Benghazi
which despite the fact that every
American has heard of it as at minimum
the site of a tragedy at maximum a site
of a massive conspiracy is actually a
city in Libya it's big it's about six
hundred thousand people roughly the size
of Denver Colorado in 2009 a
pro-democracy protests broke out in
Benghazi which then spread across the
entire country and eventually resulted
in the first Libyan civil war
revolutions are very exciting they
promise the possibility of rapid change
for good and that's exactly what we were
all hoping for after Muammar Gaddafi
generally accepted to be a pretty bad
dude was killed and his government
toppled unfortunately the usual
immediate outcome of a revolution is a
power vacuum followed by groups of
people who want very badly to control
the future of their country with guns
there was a great deal of hope that
Libya and especially Benghazi where the
protests first began would find a quick
path to stability and depending on who
you ask the Obama administration was
either too optimistic about this or
criminally negligent in pretending that
it was all okay when it really wasn't
and they just wanted to pretend it was
for political reasons let's get this
straight in this story there will be two
sides to absolutely everything and both
of those sides want very badly to
control the future of their country you
know with incessant yammering on cable
news and 85 different congressional
committees but thankfully without guns
now there isn't much controversy about
what actually happened on September 11th
2012 a group of armed militants easily
breached the consulate security experts
attempted to gather all of the personnel
and move them to the safety of a nearby
CIA compound that was much more easily
defensible to people ambassador
chris stevens and diplomat shawn smith
were in a safe room after the compound
was lit on fire both of them died of
smoke inhalation the rest of the
consulate staff was taken to the CIA
compound which was then later attacked
as well there are two security officers
both former Navy SEALs Glen Doherty and
Tyrone woods were killed by mortar fire
it was believed that ambassador Stevens
might still be alive his body wasn't
found at the consulate but it turned out
that a group of Libyans had tried to
rescue him pulled him out of the
building and taken him to a nearby
hospital where doctors were unable to
resuscitate him some people saw pictures
of the local Libyans trying to help
ambassador Stevens and put text on those
images saying that he was being attacked
or tortured by those Libyans just to
give you an idea of the kind of constant
and deep misinformation we're dealing
with here so this was an awful thing
that happened it was a terrorist attack
it was a tragedy and what you think
about it depends largely on how you feel
about President Obama and then Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton who was at the
time a head of the State Department
people predisposed to distrust in the
Democratic leadership tend to believe
that they made grave mistakes and were
criminally negligent and have so far
successfully covered up their criminal
negligence while people who find it
easier to trust Clinton and Obama tend
to accept the State Department's version
of events and that version indeed says
that grave mistakes were made in not
preparing the consulate for the
instability of the situation and that
they could have been more responsive and
that they were not but it doesn't go any
deeper than that and it doesn't go any
further up the food chain than those who
distrust the Democratic leadership say
that Clinton and Obama had a vested
interest in downplaying the severity of
the attack and yeah maybe they did
nobody wants to have a terrorist attack
on their record this viewpoint is upheld
by the fact that immediately after the
attack the CIA indicated and the
administration repeated that the attack
was just sort of a natural outgrowth of
protests that were happening because of
an anti-islam film when in fact it was
definitely a planned and organized
terrorist attack this was all very close
to the 2012 election Obama didn't want
to be talking about how he'd let a
terrorist attack happen it was weeks
before he even used the word terrorists
downplaying a crisis after it's happened
is at least to me very far away from
criminal negligence other accusations
like that then Secretary Clinton called
off troops that could have helped have
been proved over and over again to just
be made up but the State Department did
make mistakes they could have and should
have done more to protect the Consul a
short
have been acknowledged and indeed they
were acknowledged in the State
Department's own internal report since
then there have been seven more
investigations that have found nothing
new at a certain point it very clearly
went beyond simple partisan distrust and
a desire to get to whatever truth is
down there and morphed into an actual
active taxpayer-funded campaign against
the presumptive Democratic nominee for
president of course left-wing pundits
have been saying this the whole time but
right-wing pundits would then say no
we're just trying to get to the bottom
of it and left wing pundits would be
like you're at the bottom there's
nothing there and they would just yell
at each other that's how it went for a
pretty long time but then somewhat
disturbingly one of the staunchest
proponents for Benghazi investigations
came forward on national TV and said
this everybody thought Hillary Clinton
was unbeatable right but we put together
a Benghazi special committee what are
her numbers today now a lot of people on
both sides were like yeah of course of
course this is what this is about
it is a partisan it is an opportunity
for one party to gain advantage over the
other coming out and proudly saying on
national TV that you're running a series
of taxpayer-funded investigations to
advance your political party that's
that's bad that's wrong I mean it's
wrong do it in the first place but like
you can't say it and indeed that guy who
was probably going to become Speaker of
the House is no longer going to become
Speaker of the House cuz that was dumb
today in America the controversies
surrounding the Benghazi attack has
become so entrenched that there are a
lot of people whose minds will never be
changed a lot of people who will believe
forever that Obama and Clinton were
criminally negligent and a lot of people
who will believe forever that it was
never anything more than an opportunity
for the Republicans to attack the
Democrats now some people absolutely do
believe that there's a prize at the
bottom of this crackerjack box that the
president and Hillary Clinton are evil
and that this is the best chance they
have of uncovering that evil but eight
congressional investigations later
that's six more than we had after
September 11th 2001 it's teeming pretty
unlikely that we're going to find out
anything and it's seeming more likely
that this was a series of unfortunate
circumstances and significant but not
criminal mistakes for most people in
politics though Benghazi is now just a
talking point it's a way to raise money
from increasingly polarised
constituencies and also
a way to polarize those constituencies
more but even as it occasionally takes
over US politics the attack on the
consulate was a much bigger deal for
Libya after the attack aid organizations
investors business people and businesses
all left the city crushing the economy
other armies and militias saw the attack
on the consulate as brazen and
inexcusable and they took up arms and
fighting increased just led to the
eventual second Libyan civil war which
began in 2014 Benghazi now has large
areas that are completely in ruin on the
future of the city and the future of
Libya is fearfully in question so that
is what's happening in actual Benghazi
as we here in America continue to talk
about Benghazi as if it's just a 12-hour
period of time in 2012 that was of
course tragic but ultimately part of a
much larger and longer series of
tragedies John I'll see you on Tuesday
since it's only two o'clock in the
morning and I just finished at it in
this video I figured I would talk a
little more done other videos like this
in the past if you want to check those
out I'll put a link to a playlist we've
been doing it pretty much since the
beginning of Vaud brothers and I like
that we get to do videos like this
especially because we get to go past the
time limit but it's hard and it's
stressful and it's two o'clock in the
morning and I still have to edit this
bit and I don't I I haven't found many
examples of people who are trying to do
this seems a little bit like you're not
going to get a ton of views if you're
not all about outrage and you're not all
about what the other side is doing wrong
and how evil they are and so there are a
lot of people doing it if I saw someone
doing it I would either hire them or I
would just talk about them all the time
the question is am i is it just my own
bias that makes me think that all these
other people are biased I don't think it
is mostly because the way to talk about
it is from a little bit outside of the
political system and nobody seems
interested in doing that because that
detachment doesn't get people that
interested but if you know if people who
are writing about complicated issues in
a way that gives context is more as a
more full picture of something and
doesn't you know very particularly have
a goal of promoting the ideology or the
agenda of one party or another let me
know in the comments I love
to read that because it would be nice
just to help me research these because
it's really not fun to read - angry
positions and then try and figure out
which parts of their anger are real and
which parts are just then being angry
which is the majority of it another nice
thing about this being educational
videos I just can keep talking but I'm
going to stop now thank you for watching
and I hope that it was useful and not
awful